this is an incredible story that broke
this weekend we're leaked audio and
video of a private dinner with Donald
Trump has exposed that Donald Trump said
that US ambassador to the Ukraine Murray
Ivanovich should be taken out as well as
admitting that he is afraid of Bernie
Sanders Alec Torelli these are both huge
stories we're going to deal with them
one by one
now even the recording is a big story
the recording is from a dinner that
included left Parnas and igor Froman
those are the indicted henchmen of
Donald Trump's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani who Trump claimed not to know
and here we have audio and video of a
two-hour dinner where they had intimate
conversation and it's explosive this is
first of all huge because Trump has
insisted time and again he doesn't know
the guy he doesn't know left Parnas this
is secondly huge because all along we
were led to believe that Donald Trump
wasn't involved in trying to get
ambassador Jovanovic out of the way that
was ultimately admitted to by Rudy
Giuliani he was trying to get Marie
Ivanovic out of the way Trump had no
idea he wasn't involved he wasn't
calling for it and now here is audio of
Donald Trump clearly knowing exactly who
she is that she needs to be taken out
and then thirdly this is huge because
every other day we have some kind of
release related to Lev Parnas that
further incriminates and involves Donald
Trump and the people around him in the
exact mobs mobster like behavior that we
have suspected he was engaging in as
president of the United States and it
again tells us Lev Parnas must testify
in the Senate impeachment trial let's
get right to the audio take a look you
take over the biggest problem there I
think where we need to start is we gotta
get rid of the Ambassador is she still
left over from the Clinton
administration or the Ambassador where
Ukraine
[Laughter]
take her up okay there it is I mean it
this is dead to rights Trump knows who
you Voinovich is and is calling for her
removal there's a transcript of the
recording Donald Trump's exact words
appear to be quote get rid of her get
her out tomorrow I don't care get her
out tomorrow
take her out okay do it so this is a
conversation Trump is having with left
Parnas who he claims not to know he
claims not to know Lev Parnas and as I
said he previously has said you know I
I'm in pictures with a million people
just because there's a picture of me
with Lev Parnas doesn't mean I know the
guy and then we see well it's not just
with you there's pictures of Parnas with
Ivanka and Don Jr and Eric Trump and
Kellyanne Conway and Pam Bondi and Jared
Kushner and Mike Pence there's pictures
with everybody and here we have audio
and video of Donald Trump having a
dinner with Lev Parnas specifically
talking about the ambassador this has to
be repeated Trump claims he doesn't know
Lev Parnas and that he wasn't trying to
take out marie ivanovitch here is a
recording of Trump telling Lev Parnas at
a private dinner to take out Murray
Ivanovich and speaking to other people
in there in the room as well not
necessarily telling Lev to do it but
reacting to what leva
that it should be done so let's prepare
for the reactions that we expect from
the right these are these are the ones
we've heard and are going to continue to
hear number one the release of the
recording was illegal wrong unethical
mean or really the problem here the fact
that this even leaked this is a
distraction this is a political football
both sides use it when someone likes the
content of a leak they focus on the
content when they don't like the contact
content of a leak they say oh how did we
find this out this was illegal the
recordings illegal this never should
have been leaked that that's just a
political football number two they will
say listen Trump gets to decide who is
the ambassador and he's deciding in the
recording saying I want to remove an
ambassador the way policy should be done
by presidents is not at dinners with
henchmen like Lev Parnas right who work
for Trump's personal lawyer and who had
the Ambassador under physical
surveillance presidents get to decide
ambassadors there's no doubt about it
they should do it in proper venues they
should not do it in front of people like
left Parnas and using phrases like take
her out unless you run your
administration like the mob which is
exactly what Donald Trump does number
three they will say oh come on love
Parnas is an indicted crook and we
shouldn't listen to anything left Parnas
says what happened to innocent until
proven guilty all those people on the
right who love to say innocent until
proven guilty Lev Parnas shouldn't be
believed and his his recordings
shouldn't be believed because he's been
been indicted indictments are simply
allegations right but even more
seriously
they worked for Rudy crewmen and Parnas
did Trump hired Rudy it's not exactly
inspiring confidence and Trump's ability
to hire the best people and once again
you see the hyper normalization a few
days ago Trump insisted he didn't know
life harness we now have a two-hour
recording of them talking at a private
dinner and the reaction is sort of a
muted yeah Trump's a liar you know but
anyway I still support him because he's
doing the right stuff this has to be
part of impeachment Parnas must testify
that is soon going to be debated by the
Senate in the impeachment trial maybe as
soon as tomorrow or Wednesday let's now
move on to the Bernie's story that
relates to the leaked audio which is
just as fascinating if you enjoy shows
like shark tank or you're fascinated by
entrepreneurs and how they become
successful I've got something really
cool for you to check out the YouTube
channel we're partnering with called up
flip and you can find it at david
pakman.com slash up flip it's a new
channel they're hitting the ground
running with really excellent content
they're uploading new videos all the
time in each video you meet a different
entrepreneur and take an in-depth look
at how they built their business from
the ground up you can examine the
business up-close learn their strategies
for success see what it's like to live a
day in their shoes as an entrepreneur
myself I find this stuff endlessly
interesting I love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
what motivates them what the turning
points were and everyone who's featured
in up flips videos have their own really
cool insights to share but it's content
that's really easy to appreciate even if
you don't have your own business every
entrepreneur on up flip has their own
story to tell they're all fascinating
check it out if you watch my show check
out up flip this is part of a
partnership we're doing with them
they're friends of ours I think you'll
really enjoy their content it's really a
different it's unique there's something
for everybody check it out subscribe to
their channel at david pakman.com slash
up flip